hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round 10 of this
year's Tata steel we already saw what
happened in the game nepo versus ding L
and it was sort of a throwback to the
World Chess Championship Match nepo well
delivered a a very strong Victory there
if you haven't seen it is the previous
video so do check it out but now it's
Max vardan versus notbe Abdus satro
first game that we are going to cover
today as it's a rest day so we do have
time to check up on the other games and
of course we are also going to check out
the game gues versus donchenko so let's
dive straight into it it's uh it's it's
a complicated game so I'm sure you guys
will enjoy it and we already have a D4
on the board so D4 by Mox and pawn to D5
by Notre backck we have Pawn to C4 uh D
captures on C4 it's been a few times
already that notbe boldly accepted the
Queen's Gambit Knight to F3 uh sorry
Knight F3 Knight to F6 and now Pawn to
E3 with Bishop to G4 and now Bishop
captures in C4 so very standard stuff
here nothing um out of the ordinary Pawn
to E6 we have castles Knight B to D7 and
now Knight to C3 we have Pawn to C6
fighting for that D5 square and Bishop
back to E2 so you don't have to worry
about this bishop now you can even move
the Knight we have Bishop to E7 and
there are a couple of games that reach
this position but here we have Pawn to
B3 by Max and it is now as of move nine
that we have a completely new game so
okay notbe castles we have Bishop to B2
continuing development Rook to C8 and
now Pawn to a 3 asking what do you what
do you do with the bishop here so notb
just goes back and Rook to C1 continuing
development with have Knight to D5 and
now Knight to D2 offering a trade of
light score Bishops but notbe says Nope
my Bishop will be very strong on this
diagonal and your Bishop isn't really
doing all that much so Knight D to
E4 uh and the pawn to F5 now not CH
chases the Knight away from this active
E4 Square this does weaken the E6 Pawn
but uh he's claiming that Max will not
have um a way of reaching the E6 Pawn
Knight back to D2 and now Knight 7 to F6
and if you look at Notre Beck's Knights
they are placed a little bit better than
than Max's Knights this Knight on D2 is
a bit clunky here H but okay the Knight
can come to F3 maybe later on to E5 so
you know it all depends on how he plays
it uh we have Bishop to F3 hinting that
he would uh very much like to play G3
and bring the bishop back to G2 uh Pawn
to B5 and now uh Pawn to A4 attacking
the B5 Pawn inviting Pawn to B4 but Pawn
to B4 here although it looks nice after
the Knight moves to E2 it's not uh it's
not all that impressive for example Pawn
to A5 the Knight comes to F4 and already
it's uh very tricky Pawn cap Knight
captures Pawn captures and um uh you
will once this Knight lands on C4 it
will be a monster there's no b or d Pawn
to kick it away uh it will control very
very important squares from here so
instead after A4 we have just Pawn to A6
by Notre backck Queen to E2 and now
Bishop to B4 okay very nice diagonal for
the bishop we have Pawn to G3 uh and
queen to E8 now you could also activate
the queen via the A5 Square he decides
to go Queen to E8 uh Bishop to G2 and
now Bishop to H5 attacking um Max's
Queen here Queen to D3 and now Queen to
G6 and um how do you proceed here well
best would be to just bring the Knight
to F3 and say okay that nothing is
really happening this game if um let's
say Bishop captures Bishop captures the
bishop comes to D6 okay it's very nice
but the bishop will come to G2 and um
nothing really happening here however
after Queen to G6 uh MOX played Knight D
back to B1 uh and this allows nrec to go
for Bishop to D6 and now after Knight to
E2 he throws in this very nice Knight to
B4 with an attack on the queen and do
you see the big problem here yeah yes
the Knight is attacking C2 and also the
queen from G6 is x-raying the C2 square
and this is something you should not
allow the queen goes back to D1 and now
comes Pawn to F4 H threatening to to
just start capturing here but also going
for that um not C2 square but Knight to
D3 and this will come with an attack on
the bishop and on The Rook uh no idea
why I said C2 okay e captures an F3 he
grabs the pawn Knight to D3 now
attacking the rook and the bishop and
now you could go Rook to C2 to defend
the bishop but this would be wrong and
it would be very dangerous if you play
this then comes Bishop captures an F4
and now look at this Knight captures an
F4 Knight captures G4 trapping the
bishop here but it doesn't matter Bishop
captures H captures Knight captures and
now the only way to stop Checkmate here
H is to bring the queen to F3 to have
access to F3 but now you have to give up
The Rook on C2 so Queen captures Rook
Queen captures Knight Queen captures
bishop and you get this position where
black is much better black is up
material black is up um it's six pawns
to four he's he has a rook for a bishop
so of course completely winning so
instead after Knight to D3 Rook to C3
was played seemingly sacrificing the
bishop but okay you will win the Knight
back uh the material back Knight captur
on B2 we have Queen to D2 attacking the
Knight and of course Notre Beck will not
just give up the Knight he will grab
something uh while he's at it so B
captures um uh on A4 and now Bishop to
B4 uh trying to win back some material
Pawn to G4 trapping the bishop and of
course notbe um plan for this Knight
captures Pawn captures Bishop captures
uh and now Knight to G3 you want to put
as many pieces in front of the black
queen and the white king So Knight to G3
makes sense and later on uh you might
have Knight support for a move like Pawn
to F5 so here Bishop to F5 H it was uh
maybe a little bit more precise to just
trade off the light score Bishops about
okay we have Bishop to F5 uh and now now
Queen to E3 getting the queen out of the
pin so now is the time to capture Bishop
captures and C3 Knight captures also the
Knight gets developed a little bit and
now Bishop to C2 putting pressure on
that A4 Pawn so Knight C to E4 and now
Bishop captures on e4 we have Knight
captures on e4 and now Queen to G4 uh
Knight to C5 a very nice Square for the
Knight going after the E6 Pawn so Rook
to F6 defending the pawn also preparing
Rook to G6 to go after check Here and
Now Pawn to A5 um you could also just
trade here but Max never shies away from
a from a challenge so he wants to have a
complicated position later on he will be
able to eliminate the A6 Pawn he will
have a nice pass Pawn here but this also
means that Notre Beck will uh have a
pass B Pawn so okay Rook to G6
threatening Checkmate and queen to E4
stopping Checkmate here uh Rook to d8
and now you kind of have to be careful a
little bit here because Rook captures on
D4 can be played but white is by no
means um forced to recapture with the
Queen White could also just play Queen
captures on C6 and keep defending the G2
Bishop so okay Rook to E1 here and now
like I said this is a possibility
probably a very quick draw if it gets
played and now the King has to come to
F7 to help out with the defense of the
pawn and it's probably going to be a
draw Queen C7 Queen B8 Queen C7 Queen B8
and we will have a draw by three-fold
repetition so instead Rook to D6 just
adding more protection to the pawn but
now King to F1 very tricky move and it
comes on move 40 uh and you know Max was
a very very low on time when he played
this H but now his position is winning
because the queen captures on G2 threat
no longer comes with Checkmate and now
after Pawn to B4 we have Knight captures
on A6 Max creates a pass Pawn of his own
and now Rook to F6 the problem with Rook
captures on D4 now is that the queen
just captures it and you don't care
about Queen captures on G2 because the
king just moves away and you're up a
full piece you also have a pass Pawn of
course you are completely winning here
so Notre goes Rook to F6 he wants to
capture the F4 pawn and then the D4 Pawn
uh and now we have Knight captures and
B4 a slight imprecision by by Max which
still gives him a better position Knight
to C7 was just better uh the the idea
being that it just guards the queening
square so that's um to give you an
example let's say Rook captures on F4
Queen E5 you're going to play Rook F
captures and D4 Now Pawn to A6 and after
Rook to D1 looks very strong but there's
Pawn to A7 so you have to stop the
queening and after Rook d8 you will win
that Rook because the Knight defends the
square Rook captures Knight captures and
after Rook captures on E1 Queen captures
you have you're just up a bishop and
Knight of course completely winning uh
however Max played Knight captures on B4
again better for white but not as
precise uh Rook captures on F4 we have
Queen to B1 and now Rook D captures on
D4 uh so what can can M do now he plays
Knight his Knight is hanging here so he
plays Knight to D3 attacks The Rook on
F4 Rook back to f8 so you can see how
this line is not uh nearly as nice for
white as the one I've shown you uh we
have Rook to E3 uh and now Queen to G5
the idea behind this wonderful move is
that of course Queen captures on uh E3
is the threat the F Pawn is pinned but
also you just want to eliminate this
pass pawn and you don't have time to
advance it due to Queen captures an E3
so Bishop to F3 is played and notbe just
eliminates the A5 Pawn so you can see
how uh only a few moves ago you had that
line where you could just Advance the
pawn and queen it win the rook and now
the pawn is gone so objectively it's
still a draw uh but it's very very
complicated Bishop captures on C6 uh we
have Queen to A6 now attacking the
bishop and the bishop goes back Bishop
to F3 uh Queen to D6 now uh and uh Queen
to B3 so again putting pressure on this
diagonal Rook to F6 defending the pawn
and preparing The Rook to to jump jump
into the attack uh King to E2 we have
Pawn to H6 uh you know creating some
breathing room for the for the black
king uh Bishop to E4 cutting off the
king from adh7 Square we have Queen to
C7 uh and now just Bishop to G2 we have
Rook to C4 trying to somehow start
checking the white king uh now Bishop to
H3 saying okay you give one check it's
really nothing I just go back and um the
Knight covers the C1 Square so it's not
a problem uh Queen to C E8 uh and now
King back to D2 We have King to h8 and
now Queen to A2 so both players just
making moves hoping the other guy
blunders we have Rook to C6 uh and now
Queen to B3 uh we have Queen to A6 uh
here and uh Queen to B8 with check so
giving up the back rank uh but again
it's nothing we have Rook to C8 blocking
check Queen back to B3 and now Queen to
A5 with check we have King to E2 now
Queen to H5 with check so sort of
connecting with the bishop but the Rook
nicely defends it so you don't care King
to E1 we have Rook to G6 and now Bishop
captures on E6 H and it looks like um
maybe a move move too far but it's still
perfectly fine to capture this you don't
care about the back rank check Rook to
G1 check was played King to D2 and now
Rook to d8 not allowing the Knight to
move uh Bishop to H3 uh and now uh Rook
to A1 uh here we have Bishop to E6 uh
just making moves as there's really
nothing to to do here for black uh Rook
to F1 and here uh although the position
is still very much a draw it's very easy
to make a mistake and you should play a
move like King to C3 uh but in the game
King to C2 was played and now look at
this queen to G6 puts pressure on the
Knight here still it can be defended
nothing terrible has happened as of yet
King to B2 and now Rook to E8 and now
you have to play again King back to to
C3 and your position is fine but but who
who makes such a move I mean it's a uh
it's not really a position where you
make such a move and also Max was
constantly playing an increment he was
constantly on 30 seconds on the clock
making moves with five three four
seconds on the clock uh and he played
Bishop back to C4 which uh seems like
again you have nothing the problem is
there is a winning uh variation here for
nck so feel free to pause the video and
win the game uh for nck Abdus satov
while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
you can nicely connect the queen and the
rook and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Queen to F6 with
check it's not very often that our uh
you know pause the video moment um is
solved by a check but sometimes it is
the strongest move so hopefully that did
not trick you and the problem is you
don't have Queen to C3 not because of
Rook to B8 check but because of Rook
captures on F2 check and after Knight
captures and queen captures with check
uh you nicely connect with this Rook
here so whatever you play let's say play
Rook e two as the bishop guards it you
you will have to give give up The Rook
whatever you play uh Rook captures
Bishop captures Queen captures with
check and the two extra pawns will be
winning for black so that's the problem
so after Queen F6 check uh Max tried
King to A3 but now it's a king hunt and
of course on an open board uh Queen and
two Rooks you are not Escaping The King
hunt will will be successful Rook to A1
check King to B4 now comes Rook to B8
check Bishop to B5 and now Rook to first
queen to D4 with check uh Queen to C4
blocking and now a rook to B1 with check
and he was in this position un move 71
that Max varam resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you have few more moves let's say King
A3 even you can trade queens and then
you just get checkmated that's all there
is there's no no better way to play this
whatever you try here you're just going
to get checkmated uh so yeah beautiful
stuff by Notre backck tough break for
Max in the previous round we've we've
seen what happened in his game against
Paran makulu he was winning then uh he
was winning then he was winning and then
param just won I mean that incredible
end game who who who who could possibly
calculate that and now a similar thing
here against Notre backck I mean Max
played just a wonderful game he did
allow sort of Notre backck to get uh uh
the the upper hand in the beginning but
then he equalized then he was winning
and uh yeah uh not uh not the best uh
wait to to finish these two games but
what are you going to do still three
more rounds to go we'll see what happens
and I will show one more game I Will
Show donchenko versus GES but in case
you don't see that one I will also share
the standings uh uh and the results with
you so uh here it is uh sorry not that
uh here are the standings after uh 10
Rounds have been played so nrec and gesh
tied in first place with six and a half
then we have Anish gir and pran on six
with five and a half we have four people
V we Al and Yani pishi with four par
maku Jun dingen and Max vam and
Alexander donchenko and Jordan P Forest
sharing last place with three and a half
points for the moment and these are uh
okay I'm not going to show you what
happened in all of the games as you know
maybe the the result of the next game
I'm going to show you is still a mystery
to you so youit wait for that uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank Christopher and
Ruth bourette Anna oliviera mmed SES
Usman AAL Minas and hedes Teresa for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check through my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chest world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day gu
donchenko coming up soon